you know we used to go to this
underground meeting in La a lot where
guys would come in and they would debate
it was in Malibu was a phenomenal setup
because guys would come from campaign
managers from Clinton and they would
debate campaign managers from Bush and
he would sit there for two hours and
there's only 30 40 of us and they would
go back and forth that's when you guys
made a mistake here this is when you
guys made a mistake here and it was it
was incredible for me because I love
debate I think we need more debates okay
the more debate we have uh the best part
of debate is whoever that thought they
had the better ideas will be exposed the
more they talk
we can sound good for the first 10
minutes 20 minutes you can give two
minute liners that somebody else wrote
to you to respond and say Here's what
you say if they say this here's what you
say say that if they they say that but
then if we do long form a two three hour
podcast you have to talk 10-15 minutes